[Alkış]
hayatın
algoritması şimdi bu cümleyi bir yazımda
kullanmıştım ve E bu tanımlama çok
hoşuna gitmişti bir arkadaşımın hayatın
algoritması ne kadar güzel bir şeymiş ya
demişti Ve dedim ki bu çok güzel bir
başlık olur Bununla ilgili bir şey
yazabilirim İşte o hafta Tesadüf diye
bir şey yoktur Bana kalırsa telefon
geldi texte konuşma yapmam için e ve
güzel de bir ekip olduğunu biliyorum
Çünkü ben Denizli aşığıyım denizlililer
bile benim bu Denizli aşkımı anlayamadı
açıkça söyleyebilirim
bunu gerçekten bunu Uzun uzun
anlatacağım sonra paylaşımlarımdan
görebilirsiniz neden bu kadar Denizli'yi
seviyorum dedim Tamam geliyorum Daha
önce bir tedex you konuşması yapmıştım
orada etiketlerden özgürleşmek başlığı
altında bir şey yapmıştım acaba Onu mu
yapsam derken aklıma bu geldi Sonra onun
arkasından şöyle bir şey daha geldi
Annemin çok kullandığı bir cümledir
aklıma gelen başıma gelir neden hayatın
algoritması başlığını kullandım Çünkü
hayatın algoritmasıyla
internet yani sosyal medya algoritması
fena halde birbirine benziyor ve sosyal
medya algoritması hayatın algoritmasını
taklit ediyor
peki Algoritma neymiş şöyle bir bakalım
Algoritma belli bir problemi çözmek veya
belirli bir amaca ulaşmak için
tasarlanan yolmuş burada formül gibi
gösteriyor bunu anlamak zor ama
algoritmanın hayatımıza ne yaptığını
zaten aşağı yukarı hepimiz çok iyi
biliyoruz Google algoritmasını biliyoruz
bir kere Her şeyden önce dedim ki o
zaman bir elimizde hayatın algoritması
var bir de sosyal medya algoritması Ee
ben sosyal medya algoritmasını nasıl
kullanmam gerektiğini öğrendim eğitimler
aldım baktım deneme yanılma yöntemleri
ile öğrendim artık o aleti çalabiliyorum
ama hayatın algoritmasında da var onda
çok rastgele tuşlara basıyorum bazen
gerçekten hiç istemediğim sesler çıkıyor
Peki bunu çalmayı öğrenebilen ki bu
ukulele kadar işte zorlukta bir şey
acaba hayatımda daha etkili kararlar
alabilir daha iyi yol alabilir miyim
Madem tedex konuşması yapacağım Madem
bir sürü genç insan aklı Zihni Fikri
Genç insan beni izleyecek
belki onlara küçük bir ipucu verebilirim
dedim Ve dedim ki şunu şöyle maddeler
halinde bir masaya yatıralım
Özellikle sosyal mecralarda Algoritma
neleri dinliyor onları anlatmadan önce
size KL Gustav jung'un eş zamanlılık
yani Nedensellik dışı bağlayıcı bir ilke
alt başlıklı kitabından biraz bahsetmek
istiyorum ben karga gibiyimdir gerçekten
karga gibi parlak şeylere böyle
çekilirim a parlak bir şey diye bu
kitaba da öyle çekilmişti beni çok
etkilemişti e Jung her ne kadar böyle
Freud freud'la da böyle denk tutulsa da
birazcık daha böyle gizemle de ilgilenen
bunları da sorgulayan bir Eee yazar ve
Eee araştırmacı kendisi ve onun çok
önemli bir yazısı vardır eş zamanlılık
içerisinde örnek olarak hep kullanılır
diyor ki Bugün yemekte balık
yedim Sonra bir baktım ayın biriydi
Nisan'ın 1'i ve insanlar birbirine 1
Nisan balığı şakası yapıyordu o gün Es
homo totus medius PK abimo yani
bütünlüğünü bulmuş insanlar derinlikten
çekilmiş balıklar gibidir cümlesi ile
ilgili bir yazı
yazdım ve o gün bir Danışanın bana
çizdiği balık skeçlerini getirdi Come on
artık biraz fazla ileri gitmiyor mu Bu
balıklar ve akşam eve geldiğimde yastığa
işlenmiş bir canavarım sı balık motifi
gösterildi bana ve Ertesi sabah ilk
gelen danışanım bana rüyasında canavar
gibi bir balık gördüğünü anlattı Bu
kadarı fazla dedim Artık bunlar
tesadüften Biraz daha ileri gidiyor
değil mi ve bunun üzerine Koskoca kitap
yazmış o zaman tabii ki internet
algoritması bu kadar net nasıl olsa
artık hiç öyle bir şey olmadığı için
internet algoritması olmadığı için o
burada bu Nedensellik dışındaki durumda
bir şey aramış Halbuki bizim hayatımızda
şöyle bir şey var Aysel diyor ki
arkadaşına Ay hayatım yani Bununla
ilgili bir şey bile yazmadım Instagram
sürekli karşıma çanta reklamı çıkarıyor
şaşırdım kaldım aramızda konuştuğumuz
şeylerin reklamı bize geliyor artık
hepimiz biliyoruz değil mi telefonda
bazı kodlar var ve onlar algoritmaya
haber veriyor yani siz çok fazla banka
banka banka derseniz Bankayla ilgili
mesajlar alabiliyorsunuz ama hiç
çantayla ilgili konuşmamış kadın bunu
zikretmem miş ve çanta reklamı e hayatım
bütün o Fotoğrafların üzerinde çok daha
fazla durdun birilerini lel adığı
fotoğrafların çoğunda insanların elinde
çantaları var bu bile yeterli yani
Algoritma çılgınca
işliyor ve o zaman biz bu aleti
kullanmayı öğrenelim değil mi
algoritmaya en çok vereceğimiz şeylerden
bir tanesi yani algoritmayı düzgün
kullanmak için yapacağımız şeylerden bir
tanesi sosyal mecralarda da bu böyledir
süreklilik çünkü alışkanlıkların
kaderini belirler geçenlerde yine bir
tedex konuşması izledim adamın soyadı
kmı 20 saat kuralından bahsediyordu
10.000 saat kuralına karşı olarak Çünkü
10.000 saat kuralını seyredenler vardır
mutlaka 10.000 saat bir şey yaparsan
profesyonellik seviyesine ulaşırsın ve
bu insanları genelde mutsuz ediyor
biliyorsunuz ama 20 saat gibi bir süre
ayırdığında bir şeyi öğrenmiş olmak ne
kadar rahatlatıyor değil mi yani biraz
düzgün uygun hareketlerde Yani doğru
aksiyonla Hareket edersek bir şeyi çok
daha rahat öğrenebiliyoruz ve Evet
alışkanlıklarımız kaderimizi belirliyor
sosyal mecrada hesabımı büyütmek için
ben ya sabah ya da akşam mutlaka bir
paylaşım yapıyorum Günde 4 tane hikaye
mutlaka paylaşıyorum böyle olmadığı
sürece neye bakarsan o sonucu alıyorsun
Yani bir köylünün dediği gibi ne ekersen
o
çıkar o
yüzden
alışkanlıklarımız ve süreklilik bizi
profesyonelleştiği
da Süreklilik ve
alışkanlıklarımızı devam ettirmemiz
istikrar her şeyi daha iyi bir noktaya
taşıyor ikinci önemli şeylerden bir
tanesi önemli şey de sadelik şimdi
Hepimiz sosyal mecralarda ilkokul
arkadaşımızla bile arkadaşız hepimiz
Birbirimize bağlandık değil mi bunun
birçok artısı var ya da ya da birçok
konuyla birden ilgileniyoruz bu neye
sebep oluyor biliyor musunuz bu açık
büfeden yemek yemek gibi hiç tatil
köylerinde açık büfeden Yemek yediniz mi
bir sürü şeyi tabağınıza doldurursanız
çok şey yersiniz ama Aslında pek de bir
tat alamazsınız işte bunun gibi hayatta
da sosyal mecralarda da sadeleşmek
önemli ben pembik rüyalarımı bile takip
ediyordum ve Algoritma bunu çok şeyi
Takip ettiğim için Eee yanlış anlıyordu
ve Eee takipçi gelmiyordu ve keşfed
düşmüyordu ve bir gün karar verdim ve o
2500 takipçiyi 999 kişiye düşürdüm
sosyal medya danışmanım bana belirttiği
şekilde Takipçilerim arttı daha çok
görünmeye başladım Tıpkı fazla yük
olduğu için havalanamayan bir balon
gibiydim Çünkü o yüzden sadeleşmek
Hayatın her alanında önemli Tıpkı şurada
olduğu gibi bir şeyler toplu ve düzenli
olduğu zaman dolabımızda da öyledir ya
daha kolay buluruz değil mi hep Hem de
biz daha kolay
bulunuruz çok daha önemli bir konu en
önemli konulardan bir tanesi hayatta da
sosyal mecralarda da kendin olmak kendin
olursan çok daha hayatta kendinden de
memnun olursun Tıpkı Tarkan'ın dediği
gibi Başkası Olma Kendin Ol Böyle çok
daha güzelsin ya gel bana Sahici Sahici
ya da anca gidersin sosyal med alarda
kendin olmak önemli özgünlük katmak
önemli taklit edebilirsin bazı konularda
hayatta da öyle başarılı olan insanlara
örnek alabilirsin Yeter ki özgün bir
şeyler
katabilir etmekte bir sakınca yok
hayatta da yok sosyal mecralarda da yok
hatta zaten Aklın yolu bir Amerika'yı
baştan keşfetmeye gerek yok deyip size
hayatın algoritmasını hazırlarken sizin
için neyle karşılaştığım göstereceğim
Evet kervan yolda düzülür Buyurun bu
videonun adı hayatın algoritması 4 sene
önce yapmış Başak kablan YouTube'un
Google'un Instagram'ın Facebook'un
vesairenin oynadığımız oyunların genel
olarak internetin böyle hayran olduğumuz
böyle acayip bir algoritması var diyoruz
ya bu adamların Bunu nasıl yapıyorlar
Falan diyoruz Aslında internet Bu
algoritmayı tamamen hayattan kopya
etmiştir hayatın algoritması vardır
hepimizin Aslında bildiği Ama yok
saydığı bu algorit aynısını alır ve
internete uygular ve hepimiz hayran
kalırız Vay be deriz nasıl bir düşünce
tarzı bu böyle Aslında hayatın birebir
kopyasıdır
şerefsizim aklıma gelmişti
dedim resmen böyle söyledim yani dedim
ki Allah Allah Şu hale bak Hem de aynı
cümleyle söylemiş tam vazgeçmek
üzereydim dedim ki Ama akasy cığım sen
anlatmadın ve belki hayatın
algoritmasının Instagram internet
algoritmasıyla fena halde benzediğini
bilmeyen birçok insan vardır Devam et
dedim yola devam dedim kendin olmakla
ilgili önemli bir şey daha söylemek
istiyorum eğer kendin olmaz ve olmasını
gerektiğin kişi olursan o
kişinin istekleri önüne çıkacaktır
sosyal mecralarda da böyle yani takip
etmek istemediğin Aslında görmek
istemediğin ayıp olmasın diye takip
ettiğin şeyler yüzünden önünde keşfetine
düşen şeyler de aslında senin ilgilenmek
isteyeceğin şeyler olmaz yani bir şey
olmaya çalışırken kendin olmayı
kaybedersin ve İşte o zaman mutluluğun
gelmesine imkan yok çünkü sen o sırada
üstünde muşamba olan koltuk gibisin
üzerine oturduğunda zaten herhangi bir
rahatlık vermediğin gibi kendin de
kendini hiçbir zaman iyi
hissetmeyeceksiniz
geri gidiyorum bunu hep yapıyorum Bonus
veriyorum size bir de hayatın ve sosyal
medya algoritmasının dikkatini çekmek
için ne
yapmalı bu
değil sonda mı patladın
H eğlendir ama Entertainment anlamında
eğlendir dediğim Hop hadi eliler havaya
ha hep güldük değil yani insanları
eğlendir onları e kendilerini iyi
hissetmelerine sebep ol mesela Benim bir
arkadaşım var belki takip ediyorsunuzdur
Cem Özkök onun gibi birkaç hesap daha
vardır foşurt Ve inanılmaz izleniyor
yani böyle 6 milyon 16 milyon
izlenmeleri var ya bir insan temizlik
yaptığı için izlenir mi izlenir Çünkü
eğlendirmenin içerisinde rahatlatmak da
vardır Kendini iyi hissettirmek Ay o
temizledikçe ben temizlenmiş gibi
oluyorum vallahi diyenler vardır O
yüzden eğlendirmek hayatta da çok işe
yarar yani o neşeli ortama girdiğinizde
gerçekten Neşe satıyorsunuz Akasya Hanım
dükkana geldiniz yemin ediyorum Vaktin
nasıl geçtiğini anlamadık falan
dedikleri zaman ben de kendimi
hissederim genelde yani hayatta da
sosyal mecralarda da eğlendirmek geçer
akçedir
bilgilendir bilgi ne kadar kıymetli bir
şey biliyoruz değil mi Hazreti Ali'nin
sözü müydü Bana bir harf öğretenin 40
yıl köresi
olayım Çünkü bilgiyi aldığımız yerde
biliyoruz ki biz geliştik Bir şeyler
öğrendik Siz buraya Niçin geldiniz tedex
konuşmasına böyle hafta sonu cebinizden
para verip bilet alıp geldiniz ve burada
vakit harcıyorsunuz neden bilgilenmek
için bilgi kıymetli bir konuda
uzmanlaşmanın
uzmanlaşmanın size Şiddetle tavsiye
ediyorum çünkü Yapay Zeka geldiği zaman
ki geldi yani çoktan geldi Pardon
geldiği zaman diyorum hala ama gerçekten
çok Etkin olduğu zaman birçok meslek
silinecek
ama en değerli akçe Tecrübe olacak ve
tecrübeyi paylaşmak O yüzden hayatta da
sosyal mecralarda da bilgilendirmek Yine
geçer akçe ve son olarak merak uyandır
etkile alt başlığı bunun Aslında etkile
Biz etkilendiğimiz şeylere dikkat
ediyoruz değil mi Mesela az önce sevgili
Özlem Mekik hayat hikayesini anlattı
hepimizin kalbinde bir yere dokundu
kendimize benzeyen hikayeler gördüğümüz
zaman böyle bir bütünlük kurduğumuz
böyle bir ortaklık bir paydaşlık
yakaladığımız zaman tekrar gidiyoruz o
hesaba bakıyoruz ne yapmış Acaba iyi mi
o da benim gibi ben de onun gibiyim
diyoruz mesela sosyal mecralarda kimse
artık mükemmellik Aramıyor benim gibi mi
acaba diyor sosyal medyalarda Kimse
kimsenin bilgiçli Aslında çekmiyor
Bilgiç deme de bilmişlik diyeyim
deneyimini görmek istiyor ve şimdi tam
da hayatta bunu yaşıyoruz samimiyet
kazanıyor değil mi onun dışında başka
hiçbir şey değil bu küçük ipuçları yani
eğlendir bilgilendirme merak uyandır
süreklilik arz et Kendin Ol gibi
ipuçları Umarım size de bana olduğu gibi
fayda sağlar Siz de elinizdeki o Dört
Telli gitarı güzellikle güzel sesler
çalarak Eee hayatınızı yaşarsınız bir
Kızılderili sözüydü galiba Ama her
insanın bir melodisi varmış ruhunun
sesiymiş ve o öldükten sonra bile
evrende dolaşırmış
evrende dolaşacak müziğiniz güzel olsun
teşekkürler